Now, as we all know,
gravity goes down, yes?
But if we all focus,
sometimes gravity can make
things go up.
Now, does anyone have
a gum wrapper I could borrow?
Oh, I do.
Wonderful.
Thank you.
He is so hot.
Yeah, I'm not mad
at that eyeliner either.
As we all can see, this gum
wrapper is a rectangle, yes?
Now, if I fold it
one more time,
you see
it turns into a square.
Now, here's the weird part.
If I were
to unwrap this,
the wrapper is right back
to how it was.
Oh, my God.
Are these even tricks?
I'd like to use
a lovely assistant.
Does anybody...?
Shut up!
I have the "lovely"
part taken care of.
Oh, no.
Too hard?
Yeah.
No, I'd love
to be your assistant.
Okay, here's what
I want you to do.
I want you to tell me
when to stop.
Stop.
Okay.
Now tap this
one time.
Okay, this is
a story about a queen.
Aw.
Who dated a bunch
of a-holes.
It really is
your story.
Who didn't do Jack
for her, okay?
Until one day,
she found a guy
who was too--
eight of clubs,
give me that back--
who was 2 good
to be true.
She finally
found her King.
Does anybody have
a pretzel?
Oh, wait, here's one.
In your nose.
Oh, wow.
Does anyone
have a balloon?
I can't believe this.
I never thought
this would happen, but--
What?
I'm gonna (bleep)
a magician.
♪
What?
How'd you do that?
I'm afraid
that's Victoria's secret.
Ew.
Put this on.
Some people say
no glove, no love.
However, quantum mechanics
dictates--
Okay, can you just
put it on, please?
Amy, you make me
feel like an animal.
Okay.
That's-- all right.
Enough, please.
Just, can you--
Do you have an unlit match
and a Canadian coin?
No, can you just stop
with the magic?
Like we're naked,
we're in my bed.
Like you did it.
I actually can't
do it tonight.
Why?
'Cause there's something
blocking my way.
What?
(grunts)
Oh, my God!
Oh, my--
ew, ew, ew.
All right, enough.
No more magic.
Your wish
is my command.
Let's still like
a magic saying.
Oh.
Man, you're pregnant!
What?
No, I'm not.
Oh, my God.
I can feel it kicking!
Ew!
Josh, this is cra--
Josh?
(wind blowing)
Magic.